wir sind auf einer reise mitten in das
leben der sie sind ureinwohner alaskas
vier generationen in einem boot der
neunjährige viktor ein 86-jähriger uropa
trimble dessen sohn bobby vater von
curtis
die gilbert familie erlebt den
klimawandel hautnah im arctic village
oberhalb des polarkreises
wir wollen mit ihnen reden über ihren
kampf für den erhalt der natur die durch
neue ölbohrungen weiter zerstört werden
könnte der wasserspiegel im fluss ist so
niedrig wie sie es noch nie erlebt haben
die böschungen sacken ab auch weil der
permafrostboden die ice durchsetzt
geschichte in der erde weiter auf tour
wir sind an der jagdhütte fischen und
jagen ohne das könnte das volk der
griechen nicht überleben das ist
wörtlich gemeint denn alle
nahrungsmittel zu kaufen und in eine der
abgelegensten gegenden der usa zu
bringen können sich die menschen hier
einfach nicht leisten aber die tiere von
denen sie sich ernähren spüren den
klimawandel karibus elche fischer auch
vögel sind seltener geworden erzählt uns
gem
es war früher so laut tausende von
vögeln die singen wir konnten kaum
schlafen im lager
jetzt hört man nichts mehr
wir sehen viel vom klimawandel all die
seen trocknen aus die caribo steen
eigentlich zu einer bestimmten zeit
vorbei jetzt kommen sie manchmal nicht
und wenn sie nicht mehr kommen irgendwo
anders hin ziehen dann wissen wir nicht
was passiert wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen
alle menschen und tiere seien bedroht
meint trimble und die politik müsse sich
endlich einig seinem kampf gegen den
klimawandel
jeden tag streiten sind republikaner und
demokraten
sie lösen keine probleme
sie wissen nicht was sie tun wenn das so
weiter geht artet das nach der nächsten
wahl vielleicht sogar in einen krieg aus
der politische streit markt weit
entfernt sein vom artig village aber der
lebensraum der knapp 200 menschen hier
und der rund 5000 anderen geschehen in
der region war in den jahren der tramp
regierung akut bedruckt der präsident
hatte weite teile ihres landes für die
förderung von öl freigegeben die
ureinwohner banken um den erhalt ihrer
traditionellen lebensweise
und um die zukunft ihrer kinder
ihr alltag ist schwierig genug
wasser holen sie in kanistern weil ihre
häuser nicht angeschlossen sind nur in
der schule gibt es duschen und toiletten
[Musik]
im einzigen laden sind die lebensmittel
drei vier mal so teuer wie im rest der
usa
ohne das fleisch der karibus könnten die
griechen im winter nicht überleben
[Musik]
sarah james singh das karibu lied sie
will der welt vermitteln dass das
nordamerikanische rentier den menschen
hier heilig ist
es ist unser leben unser essen auf den
tisch unsere werkzeuge dass unsere
kleidung unsere lebensweise
ja auch unser schutz unsere hütten waren
aus karibu haut es symbolisiert wer wir
sind wir haben ein menschenrecht zu sein
wer wir sind es definiert uns
sarah kämpft an vorderster front gegen
den klimawandel sie hat vor den
vereinten nationen gesprochen um das
arctic national wildlife refuge
amerikas größtes naturschutzgebiet vor
der ölindustrie zu bewachen
eine einzigartige tier und pflanzenwelt
im polarkreis fast 80.000
quadratkilometer
die neue regierung in washington hat die
ölbohr rechte nun suspendiert aber es
müsse viel mehr geschehen meint er
der handel ist schnell genug
es wird immer noch viel zu viel
produziert was wir nicht wirklich
brauchen was wir am ende doch wegwerfen
oder verbrennen
wir müssen all das auch reduzieren
langsam wächst der ärger denn die dürre
in diesem sommer trocknet nicht nur
flüsse und seen aus der nation der
stellvertretende stammesführer nimmt uns
mit auf den hügel über den normalerweise
bei die karibus ziehen würden künftig
vielleicht immer seltener
das hier ist licht eine schlechte für
die karibus seine wichtige nahrung jetzt
knochentrocken
überall gibt es solche alarmzeichen
deshalb hat lennart kein verständnis für
einige ureinwohner an der küste im
norden vor allem vom volk der ihn opiat
die für die ölförderung sind
das ist reine gier die ganze welt hängt
am geld die menschen hier im arctic
village brauchen das nicht
eigentlich bräuchten sie nur dass es
nicht schlimmer wird
aber die veränderungen in der natur sind
unübersehbar auch unumkehrbar der yukon
river ist so ausgetrocknet dass der
lachs bestand gefährdet ist die
regierung alaskas verteilt fisch an die
griechen als spende wir fliegen nach
fairbanks der zweitgrößten stadt des
nördlichsten us-bundesstaates hier
schlägt der klimawandel wellen
wortwörtlich straßen sacken ab weil der
permafrost taut die bautrupps kommen
kaum nach mit reparatur auch häuser und
die menschen in ihnen sind betroffen
[Musik]
vor einem jahr wagte der fiberglas stab
von professor dr -ing noch 50 60 cm aus
der erde jetzt verschwindet erfasst
bisher auf die durch eisschicht im boden
treffen
wenn die permafrost platten schmelzen
sagt erst der boden ab dann so sagt da
kippen und sterben das co2 das sie
gebunden haben entweicht in die
atmosphäre
befeuert die globale erwärmung
könnte dann nicht auch die große öl
pipeline ins wanken kommen wenn der
boden immer weicher tag hält sie für
stabil weil sie einst erdbeben fest
gebaut wurde aber mittlerweile braucht
die pipeline regelrechte kühl stäbe
damit der permafrost unter ihrer nicht
weiter auftaucht
in den pfeilern befindet sich ein
kühlmittel das im winter durch die
restwärme im boden aufgeheizt wird und
diese wärme nach oben ab leitet das eis
in der erde bleibt länger stabil
die betreiberfirma schickt solche
messungen durch die pipeline um jedes
absackten jede dehnung oder risse der
leitung frühzeitig zu entdecken also
kein anlass zur sorge
in einigen teilen alaskas haben wir 700
meter dicken permafrost es dauert
jahrhunderte um das zu schmelzen und
selbst wenn einige der oberen schichten
über jahrzehnte oder jahre schmelzen
dauert das eben jahre oder jahrzehnte
nicht tage stunden oder minuten
das wird also keinen zusammenbruch der
pipeline verursachen
doch zwei stunden nördlich von fairbanks
an diesem hang befürchten umweltverbände
ein platzen der pipeline bei der
permafrost rund um die tragseile immer
instabiler wird die betreiberfirma
steckt millionen dollar in
sicherungsmaßnahmen
wissenschaftler der us regierung
erforschen in der region in einem tunnel
was sich in den vereisten erdschichten
alaskas tod der permafrost taut immer
schneller
knochenreste seit zehntausenden von
jahren eingefroren werden freigelegt
zum beispiel die eines mannes
nach neuesten erkenntnissen deutscher
experten entstehen beim auftauen von
permafrost riesige mengen von methangas
das als grösster klimakiller geht
wir treffen uns mit rick steiner dem
wohl bekanntesten umweltexperten alaskas
er warnt die regierung des bundesstaates
nehme das problem nicht ernst genug eine
wirksame kontrolle der ölindustrie gebe
es nicht weil diese über viele
jahrzehnte mit ihren steuern einen
großteil der staatsausgaben alaskas
finanziert habe
wir trauen der ölindustrie nicht auch
nicht der staatsregierung die von den
steuern für die ölindustrie abhängig ist
es folgt der vereinigten staaten muss
mehr beitragen und die beiden
administration sollte alles tun im
kongress und per anordnung um uns von
dieser abhängigkeit dieser sucht nach öl
abzubringen das ist wichtig
der druck auf die ölindustrie zeigt
wirken als in der tram zeit bohrrechte
im arctic wildlife refuge versteigert
wurden boten die konzerne nicht mit
alaskas regierung kaufte die lizenzen
die nun von präsident biden eingefroren
wurden überraschenderweise aber gab die
beiden administrationen gleichzeitig
grünes licht für neue bohrungen in einem
anderen schutzgebiet
es gibt da eine schizophrenie in der
beiden administration sie will wohl
einige abgeordnete besänftigen um deren
stimmen für andere vorhaben zu bekommen
die nichts mit dem erhalt der natur zu
tun haben also einerseits die
ölbohrungen im arctic refuge zu
verbieten aber
gleichzeitig die förderung im
schutzgebiet in der zentralarktis zu
genehmigen das macht keinen sinn
deshalb kämpfen amerikas ureinwohner
weiter für den erhalt ihres lebensraums
im august versammelten sich abordnungen
von stämmen aus allen landesteilen in
washington sie hoffen auf die
unterstützung eines wichtigen
regierungsmitglied das innenministerium
leitet nun erstmals eine der ihren der
paland stammt aus dem volk der laguna in
new mexico
[Musik]
ausgerechnet sie hat die genehmigung für
die neuen bohrungen in alaska
unterschrieben
bernadette dem je traf leitet das
koordinationsbüro der coach in in
fairfax sie ist enttäuscht dass einem
teil des volkes der inubit im äußersten
norden die ölförderung wichtiger ist als
der schutz der natur
sie wollen über 80.000 tonnen an
räumfahrzeugen ranschaffen
über 50.000 tonnen wald unterpflügen
obwohl sie dabei mit 50 prozentiger
sicherheit auch die höhlen von eisbären
plattwalzen
verraten sie ihre traditionen
ich verstehe einfach nicht wie wir als
indigene völker geld über unsere
gesundheit und unsere tiere stellen
können
das gab es noch nie außer jetzt hier
oben
wir fliegen in den äußersten norden über
das brux massiv an dessen nordende die
koste planes beginnen die landesebene am
arktischen meer
oder oetker weg in der sprache der inuit
ist der nördlichste auch der vereinigten
staaten
hier leben rund 5000 menschen viele
arbeiten in der ölbranche auch hier sind
die lebensbedingungen hat die preise
hoch vor allem die ureinwohner sind auf
jagen und fischen angewiesen vor allem
auf den walfang für den sie eine
ausnahmegenehmigung haben
hier liegen noch die reste eines wals es
ist kühl 45 grad celsius sind normal im
sommer aber in den letzten jahren
kletterten die werte auch schon mal auf
27 grad der permafrostboden taut
turin levitt zeigt uns den eiskeller in
dem ihre familie das fleisch der wale
lagert rundum gekühlt durch die vereiste
erde das fleisch in schichten mit schnee
dazwischen
[Musik]
maria lemmen erzählt auch dass immer
mehr dieser natürlichen eisschränke
kaputt gehen eben bei der permafrost
schmilzt
in einem jahr stand der voll wasser wir
konnten ihn nicht benutzen weil das jahr
wärmer war
mit riesigen sandsäcken kämpfen sie an
gegen den klimawandel denn die
herbststürme sind so heftig dass die
küstenlinie erodiert auch am haus von
den schwiegereltern
hüten aus alten zeiten auf einmal
freigelegt häuser drohen abzustürzen
jedes jahr werden die säcke neu am ufer
platziert jedes jahr werden sie von der
flut weggerissen
marie ist der verwaltungschef der in
opiat turin und er sind ständig im
krisenmodus häuser drohen zu überfluten
ein wichtiger sei für die
wasserversorgung sicher der einfach weg
als der permafrost schmolz im winter ist
das eis auf dem meer dünner und
gefährlicher für die jäger und doch sind
die in opiat auf die öl förderung
angewiesen weil sie die einkünfte
brauchen auch wenn manche alle bohrungen
am liebsten sofort stoppen würde
natürlich denke dass einige es ist ein
elefant im raum über den niemand redet
es ist hart den frust einfach
runterzuschlucken denn was machst du
wenn du die einnahmen oft mehr hat
wir müssen das zu diesem zeitpunkt so
annehmen wie es ist ich weiß dass die
regionalbehörde sehr ernsthaft nach
alternativen einnahmequellen sucht
es finanziert unsere strafen unsere
schulen notunterkünfte
alles was uns hilft zu überleben was wir
brauchen auf das wir angewiesen sind wir
haben keine wahl
ich glaube ein gesunder ausgleich wäre
möglich zu dem wir alle beitragen indem
wir kleinere weniger benzin schluckende
autos fahren mehr recyceln dinge die wir
alle mitmachen können aber wir sind
darauf angewiesen
die nokias stecken in einer zwickmühle
sie neue ölbohrungen riskieren sie die
zukunft ihrer kinder das gleiche gilt
wenn sie so weitermachen
vorerst alle mauern hat 15 kinder
er erzählt uns dass eisbären fleisch
sehr gut schmeckt aber
er will dass eisbären bestmöglich
geschützt werden vor ist fährt mit uns
am sommercamp vorbei von dem aus die
nokia hat in den eisfreien monaten
fischen und jagen
[Musik]
und dann sind wir da
mitten in schotter und sand am aller
nördlichsten punkt der usa
diese karge schönheit soll erhalten
bleiben meint forest die veränderungen
seien ja vielleicht doch nur teil eines
natürlichen kreislaufs der erdgeschichte
ich stelle mir das als zyklus vor
vielleicht sollten wir das eben alle 50
jahre erwacht
denn als das eis in diesem jahr kam
schien mir das gut solide und es blieb
länger als in den vergangenen zwei
jahrzehnten
vielleicht schließt sich also wieder
einmal der kreis
hoffen entgegen der facc die co2 werte
in der atmosphäre liegen heute mit 420
ppm auf einem höchstwert seit über drei
millionen jahre früher brauchten große
schwankungen zehntausende von jahren
jetzt verändern menschen das klima
schneller als das sie jemals geschah das
eis der erde auch ihr lebensraum
schmilzt in einer geschwindigkeit wie es
die welt noch nicht gesehen
beim jetzigen tempo ist die chance zur
anpassung gleich null
auch die griechen im artikel iec
fürchten um ihren lebensraum und ihre
lebensart aber sie haben auch ein stück
weit verständnis für die nokia
sie lieben ihre ware sie lieben ihre
seehunde ihre fische ihre karibus und
ihre elche auf dem tisch genauso gern
wie ich es weil es gut für uns ist wie
eine medizin aber sie sind gefangen in
den zwei welten in denen sie leben
müssen
vor uns liegen harte zeit ich sorge mich
um die nächste generation nächste
mission
ihre zukunft hängt nicht nur davon ab ob
hier wirtschaftliche chancen ohne die
ölförderung entstehen nur wenn die
menschheit den klimawandel wirklich
stopp bleibt ihr einzigartiger
lebensraum am polarkreis
erhalten
[Musik]